-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy-nominated comedian,
producer, and actor you know
from his work
in "Big Mouth",
"Oh, Hello on Broadway",
and "Don't Worry Darling".
His stand-up special,
"Nick Kroll: Little Big Boy"
is now streaming globally
on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-Part of the reason she wanted
to break up with me
is she didn't, like, find me,
like, masculine enough.
Like, she wanted a guy with,
like, sleeves of tattoos
who could drive stick,
could ride a motorcycle.
And I'm just never gonna be
the guy who rides a motorcycle.
If I were, I'd be the guy
at the back of the pack
who's like, "Oh, no, I'm gonna
miss the light.
Aw, I'm gonna get split up
from the fellas.
I was really looking forward to
rumbling through a neighborhood
and ruining people's day."
-Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend,
Nick Kroll, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hello, friend!
-Hello!
-This is a very -- These last
couple weeks have been
very special for me.
I haven't seen you in forever.
And then I was lucky enough,
obviously, I'm seeing you now.
You little boy is
1-and-a-half years old.
-Yes.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you very much.
-How is -- What's he into?
-He's into S&M.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's so crazy.
-Yeah.
-It's so weird I never --
-Well, yeah, and what're you
gonna do, 'cause you gotta
support what --
-You gotta support the kid.
-Yeah, you just let them choose
their own path.
-He's on his journey.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-He's also -- besides that, he's
really into high fives
right now.
-Uh-huh.
-High five, high five?
-Oh, he asks for it, yeah.
-Yeah.
-So, like, we'll be walking
the streets,
and we're literally walking
through Brooklyn
on Saturday,
and he's just going,
"High five, high five?"
And so, like, and he's
in my little BabyBjorn
so I just have this tiny human
being like, "High five,
high five?"
-[ Laughs ]
-And it's so interesting to see
who will high five a baby
and won't.
-Yeah.
Is it who you think?
Can you tell now when you see
someone coming,
if they're gonna do it or not?
-Kind of.
-Yeah.
-Middle-aged white guys don't.
-Right.
-Like --
-Well, that's the thing.
I mean, I say,
as a middle-aged white guy,
you don't know what you're gonna
get canceled for.
-[ Laughs ] These days.
-[ Laughs ]
It used to be in the '80s
you could high five a baby.
-Different time.
The political correctness police
won't let you high five
a random baby anymore.
-[ Laughs ]
-But the truth is
you will get canceled.
-Yeah, I've been lucky enough
over the years
to meet your parents.
They're incredibly wonderful.
I know they're wildly
supportive of you.
-Yes.
-And yet, like, a lot
of parents
of people who do stand-up sets,
they get poked fun of a lot.
You maybe have, and I'm not just
saying this,
one of the best bits about moms
I've ever seen
in a stand-up act.
It is remarkably great.
I've been quoting it ever since
I've seen it,
but how did they react to it?
-You know, it's like I talk --
I'll just, like --
I'll set it up quickly in some
way, if that's --
I'm lifting the curtain here,
folks.
-[ Laughs ]
-So, you know, moms are --
I have no shorter fuse
with anyone in my life
than I do my own mother.
-Yeah.
-You know, like, it doesn't
matter --
My mom could be like,
"I clipped an article
about the LA Art Deco movement."
And I'm like, "Why would you do
that, Mom?"
You know art deco's, like,
my least favorite architectural
movement!"
-[ Laughs ]
-And then, dad's, like, get away
scot-free.
It's like I remember my Dad
being like, "Hey, son,
wanted to come to your baseball
game today, but then didn't."
-[ Laughs ]
-And I'm just like, "That's
okay, Daddy."
-[ Laughs ]
-So, the joke is --
there's a lot more.
You should watch the special,
and -- but, you know,
and it's so weird,
because -- and I feel like it's
similar with your parents --
it's like we are -- I don't know
if we're the exception,
but we come from, like, very
loving, supportive...
-We really do.
-...families.
-And I think families who
thought there was something cool
and noble about comedy.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-And so my parents came
to my shows
before I was doing anything.
I was in the back of, like,
weird VHS, like, rental stores.
-Yeah.
-It was porn.
And so they would come
to those shows,
and they would watch me bomb.
They'd come to open mics.
They'd come to bringer shows
where they would have to pay
like $40 to see me and a bunch
of, like, 10 people
who've never done comedy before.
And, like, how do I repay them
to just, like very publicly
make fun of them on a stand-up
special on Netflix,
which you can't even get
on VHS anymore?
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-And so I want to take
this opportunity
to look -- find my camera.
-There you go.
-That's my camera.
-Yeah.
-I want to say to my Mom
and my Dad,
thank you very much for always
supporting me.
I'm so sorry that I have made
fun of you in my stand-up,
and also, frankly,
you deserve it.
[ Laughter ]
But I love you,
and I really am grateful.
I'm grateful to my family.
I'm grateful to my wife
for helping --
-I actually want to ask
about your wife,
because I've talked about mine
in stand-up, as well.
We'll be right back with more
from Nick Kroll.